[Musik]
jetzt eine 19 Uhr halbzeitausgabe in
aller Kürze und damit einen schönen
guten Abend kurz vor dem Jahrestag des
ukrainekriegs heute große Auftritte der
Präsidenten Russlands und der USA zwei
reden die gegensätzlicher nicht sein
konnten zunächst zu Vladimir Putin er
machte dem Westen wieder schwere
Vorwürfe und kündigte an den atomaren
Abrüstungsvertrag newstart auszusetzen
Nina nibagall berichtet
mit Spannung war erwartet worden was
Putin in seiner jahresbotschaft wohl
verkünden ob er eine neue Richtung
vorgeben würde was folgte war vor allem
mein best of russischer Propaganda eine
Abrechnung mit dem Westen
wir haben nur Gewalt genutzt und tun das
immer noch um ihn zu stoppen
russland habe den Konflikt mit der
Ukraine friedlich lösen wollen voll
verantwortlich sei der Westen es sind
Erzählungen die man aus Putins reden
kennt nach gut 90 Minuten lässt er dann
doch noch eine politische Bombe platzen
sie wollen uns eine strategische
Niederlage zufügen und unsere
nuklear-anlagen bezwingen ich bin
deshalb gezwungen heute bekannt zu geben
dass Russland seine Teilnahme an dem
Vertrag über strategische offensiv
Waffen aussetzt damit ist der letzte
verbliebene atomwaffenkontrollvertrag
mit den USA gemeint keine Zeichen der
Entspannung Wladimir Putin sprach heute
nicht davon wie der Krieg beendet werden
könnte sondern er kündigte
beispielsweise an das russische Soldaten
alle sechs Monate Heimaturlaub von der
Front bekommen sollen das zeigt dass
Wladimir Putin davon ausgeht dass der
Krieg bis auf weiteres zum russischen
Alltag dazu gehört
seine Botschaft richtete sich also auch
nach innen an die Russinnen und Russen
aber am Ende wirkte es vor allem wie
eine Pflichtveranstaltung
[Applaus]
weiter nach Warschau von dort kam vor
einer Stunde die Putin Replik des
US-Präsidenten nach seinem Besuch in
Kiew wollte Joe Biden dem Nato-Partner
Polen den Rücken stärken und wieder
betont er Geschlossenheit und
Solidarität aber nicht nur mehr von
Heikes lanski
es ist wieder ein Besuch mit hoher
Symbolkraft der US-Präsident zum zweiten
Mal in Warschau nach dem russischen
Überfall auf die Ukraine Joe Biden
dankte Polens Präsident du da für die
großzügige Unterstützung des
angegriffenen Nachbarlandes Polen hat
mehr als 1,5 Millionen ukrainische
Flüchtlinge aufgenommen und das Land mit
Milliarden unterstützt vor der Kulisse
des Warschauer königsschlosses
beschworen beiden erneut den
Zusammenhalt des Westens
es sollte kein Zweifel geben unsere
Unterstützung für die Ukraine wird nicht
nachlassen die NATO wird nicht geteilt
wir werden nicht müde die Ukraine werden
niemals ein Sieg für Russland soiden zu
Putins Ankündigung seine Beteiligung am
letzten verbliebenen
atomwaffenkontrollvertrag mit den USA
auszusetzen kein Wort nur so viel
dieser Krieg ist niemals eine
Notwendigkeit es ist eine Tragödie
Präsident Putin hat diesen Krieg gewählt
jeden Tag geht dieser Blick weiter es
ist seine Wahl er könnte den Krieg mit
einem Wort beenden es ist einfach
morgen trifft sich Präsident beiden mit
den sogenannten Bukarest 9 den NATO
Verbündeten an der Ostflanke geografisch
eine Art abwehrring gegen Russland auch
das wieder ein Besuch mit hoher
Symbolkraft
[Musik]
unser Washington hat den Auftritt in
Warschau mit verfolgt Elmar an wen hat
beiden seine Rede vor allem gerichtet
und was war für dich das
bemerkenswerteste
im Grunde genommen an alle Menschen die
die Freiheit lieben und damit meinte er
nicht nur die die Waffen liefern an die
Ukraine oder die Flüchtlingen Aufnahme
gewähren sondern er meinte ganz
besonders auch die russische Bevölkerung
er hatte ihnen gesagt dass sie nicht
Schuld tragen an diesem Krieg Wladimir
Putin allein und diese müsste man
Widerstand leisten wir allen autokarten
aber bemerkenswertesten fand ich am
Schluss seiner Rede dass er gesagt hat
die Entscheidungen der nächsten fünf
Jahre entscheiden über die Zukunft wir
stehen gewissermaßnahmen Scheideweg ich
glaube er plädiert hier für eine Art
Neuauflage der alten Weltordnung aber
eben besser und gerechter als sie bisher
war und das ist anstrengend und daran
wird sich vielleicht entscheiden ob die
Geschlossenheit des Bündnisses auch in
den nächsten Monaten vielleicht gar
Jahren erhalten bleibt danke für die
Einordnung nach Warschau elmerson
Deutschland will den Menschen in der
türkisch-syrischen Erdbebenregion
nachhaltig helfen das erklärten die
Ministerin in bärbock und Epheser bei
ihrer Reise in das betroffene Gebiet in
garsiantep in der Region sprachen sie
mit Helfern und mit Opfern kurz zuvor
hatte die Erde in der Provinz hartei
wieder heftig gebebt mehrere Menschen
starben hunderte erlitten Verletzungen
Michael verlaat violand berichtet
es sind die bislang schwersten nachgeben
schon wieder müssen Leichen aus den
Trümmern geborgen werden dabei ist das
Trauma von vor zwei Wochen noch lange
nicht überwunden hier in der türkischen
Provinz hathai übernachteten bereits
viele wieder in ihren beschädigten
Häusern ein fataler Fehler doch wo
können die Verletzten hin selbst das
Krankenhaus in Iskenderun musste wegen
der neuen Beben geräumt werden auch in
Syrien waren die Auswirkungen am Abend
zu spüren
die Leute waren in Panik alle in der
Stadt hatten Angst und sind auf die
Straße gelaufen
bundesaußenministerin bärburg und
Innenministerin Fräser reisten heute ins
türkische Erdbebengebiet und sie
brachten 13 Tonnen deutsche Hilfsgüter
für den türkischen Katastrophenschutz
mit darunter Zelte Feldbetten
Schlafsäcke
auch die finanzielle Hilfe wird
verdoppelt bärbock versprach weitere 50
Millionen Euro für die Türkei und Syrien
wir werden auch nach zwei Wochen dieses
furchtbaren Bebens dieser furchtbaren
Katastrophe mit unserer Hilfe nicht
nachlassen sondern erst recht dafür
sorgen dass alle Menschen hier vor Ort
erreicht werden können dass sie nicht
vergessen werden das Versicherten die
Ministerinnen den Menschen noch einmal
selbst in einer Zeltstadt in der Provinz
Karaman Maras
ein deutsch-irana ist im Iran zum Tode
verurteilt worden der 67-Jährige
jumpschied Charmed gehörte eine
Oppositionsgruppe an er war vor
zweieinhalb Jahren aus Dubai in den Iran
verschleppt worden der Iran wirft ihm
Terrorismus vor Außenministerin bärburg
bezeichnete das Urteil als inakzeptabel
es habe nicht mal ansatzweise einen
fairen Prozess gegeben hat kann noch
Berufung einlegen von Rossellini bis
Pilcher Nadia Teller konnte Farm fatal
aber eben auch Familienfilm die
Schauspielerin ist jetzt mit 93 Jahren
gestorben berühmt wurde sie mit einem
Skandal Film der 50er das Mädchen
Rosemarie die Geschichte einer
Frankfurter Edelprostituierte im Kino
und später im Fernsehen oft an ihrer
Seite jemand weitergelder drehte mehr
als 120 Filme und Serien
zum Wetter so viel auch morgen wieder
ungewöhnlich mild mehr Einordnung zu den
Reden von beiden und Putin im heute
journal um 21 Uhr mit Dunja Hayali so
viel von uns danke schönen Abend und bis
morgen und jetzt viel Spaß beim Fußball
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend in der Nacht lässt
der Regen relativ rasch nach der Regen
der hier im Norden fällt ansonsten
bildet sich Nebel und die Temperaturen
gehen zurück auf bis zu 0 Grad im Osten
-2 ganz im Süden und 7 Grad in der
norddeutschen Tiefebene und morgen erst
einmal trockenes Wetter nach Norden hin
mehr Wolken im Süden Sonnenschein am
Nachmittag und späten Abend dann von
Westen Herr neuer Regen bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 5 bis 15 Grad
ungewöhnlich mit wird es erneut morgen
und die nächsten Tage ja es ist immer
etwas Regen dabei viel wird es nicht
sein sechs bis 13 Grad am Donnerstag und
vor allem dann am Samstag spürbarer und
damit ein schöner Abend